c'est vraiment le raisin de corinthe et
avec une richesse mondiale 0 me de miel
on a déjà des arômes de pruneaux de
fruits confits de fruits frais pour
dessécher premier passage dans les
vignes du clos du bourg à vouvray pour
une vingtaine de vendangeurs objectif
plier les raisins atteint de pourriture
noble des raisins qui donneront des vins
moelleux grâce au développement de cette
pourriture pas tout à fait comme les
autres
c'est un champignon le vôtre et fils
cinerea c'est un champignon qui est en
quelque sorte consomment l'eau qui vont
plus loin de dans le grain de raisin
l'égard de garde le sucre l'idéal c'est
d'avoir des brouillards matinaux et
ensuite une très belle journée de rêve
c'est là que champignons se développe
dans les collisions maxime parce que le
brouillard amen à tout petit peu
d'humidité ou de champignons ont besoin
d'humidité et ensuite le soleil sèche le
raisin derrière contrairement au
vignoble de sauternes louvre et ne
produit pas chaque année des vins
liquoreux et la vendange parties restent
l'apanage des grands millésimes et en 80
à 90 on a produit à peu près la version
10 % d'un vol en 95 on a produit 25 à
30% il quand même là la production
endemol s'est abaissée
j'essaye d'évaluer tout à l'heure mais
ça doit faire dans 5-6 hectolitres hl ha
en volume c'est parce que tu crois que
ça va se passer
7 6 6 7 8 autres devises 8 potentiel
très bonne année exceptionnelle
peut-être parce que après 89 et 90 c'est
quand même difficile de trouver la même
qualité mais c'est une très bonne heure